so cold storage is part of our phone
courage interactive which will be
tomorrow night at the downtown
independent now the film was really 20
years in the making he tell us about
that what why so long what that's a good
well I don't know really other than you
know I came up with the idea you know
back in the 80s and it was it was one of
those odd things where I was driving
back from California and I sort of came
up with the idea when I was going
through the mountains of Tennessee it
was like three o'clock in the morning
it's like wow what if I was to go off
this cliff and some mountain man found
me and and and that sort of was sort of
the sort of the kernel for the idea and
I went back and started riding it with
my friend my writing partner more Kim
right so he and I came up with you know
within six months we had a full draft
and then we kept tinkering with it and
changing it and I decided to go out
start raising money well at that point
I'd never really made a film I'd made
short films and I had never done a
feature film and um killer a roadkill
look you know so I'm still out there
trying to make something happen and I
was trying to get real money I thought
well if I'm going to make my first film
I got to have at least you know a
million dollars yeah so I was just that
naive to think that you know to make you
first film you got to have you know the
real money you know cuz I said none do
the budget said worked on real films my
background special effects makeup I
worked on you know big-budget films so I
knew all the equipment it took to make a
movie and I thought that's what I needed
but I worked on you would add to Sam
Raimi and Sam said you don't need all
this just get your camera and shoot a
movie so after after that you know so
that was that was like that 10-year
period of trying to find a million
dollars to do cold storage and you know
after i met with Sam and Sam say
just grab a camera and start making a
movie and that's when a cop turned
around it's like you know he's right I
don't need you know a million dollars to
make a movie so I went out deliberately
wrote a script with my writing partner
mark that we could shoot for like ten
thousand dollars and I grabbed my super
8 camera and I ran out and that's how it
came up a killer and we shot kill her
and then and then then I kind of started
stepping up with each one of them and
then eventually 20 years of like hits
gone by and I pulled it off the shelf
and dusted off and said now it's the
time to make this movie and so that's
sort of how it came about it was a
learning process you can't start out
with stars in your eyes you got to start
out a little smaller than kind of work
your way up and and I'm still trying